scusate devo fare un po di feng shui
quadro posizionare
oggetti chi non tiene questi oggetti a
casa sapere scommetto che qualcosa
qualsiasi cosa dirà sul palco oggi ho
ragione io vero si ha paura un po ho
avuto un po di problemi a portarla
queste col treno
allora non ho visto di di cosa vi parlo
mi parlò di africa vi parla di africa vi
parlo di leoni d'africa è è un posto è
ignoto e inconoscibile è un buco nero è
un luogo indistinto fatto di soprattutto
malattia povertà disperazione guerre le
foto di donne tristi le foto di bambini
col ventre gonfio e con un sacco di
mosche negli occhi è un luogo dove molto
spesso manca la conoscenza il vero leone
in africa a parte quello fisico
hicks sunt leones mai come in questo
caso è vero
in realtà è lo stereotipo perché lo
stereotipo lì dove non c'è la conoscenza
lì dove la conoscenza lascia il vuoto
entro lo stereotipo e fa a pezzi la
conoscenza e la dilania la sbrana perché
annulla le sfumature le complessità i
chiaroscuri tutte quelle zone di grigio
che invece un giornalista un reporter
uno storyteller come va di moda dire
adesso dovrebbe invece raccontare
ecco oggi cercherò di lottare contro
quel leone no contro quello quel grande
stereotipo che abbraccia l'africa ogni
tanto mi dicono ma come mi piacerebbe
andare in africa e che come dire come mi
piacerebbe andare in eurasia trapani
oslo stoccolma istanbul come se fosse la
stessa cosa
oppure mi dicono ma com'è la situazione
lì lì dove perché tokyo istanbul certo
ma che cosa mangili a volte la pizza vi
stupirà ma c'è anche la pizza allora e
oggi cercherò di dimostrarvi con un po
di oggetti un po di aneddoti che non è
lì ma ci sono tanti lì
l'africa non è un paese è un continente
in continente con 54 stati 3mila etnie e
2000 lingue parlate
non è poco devo anche aggiungere una
cosa che il mio la mia presenza oggi ho
più un atto sentimentale
che scientifico vero e proprio perché io
amo profondamente l'africa ci lavoro da
alcuni anni e vi raccontano delle storie
che non esauriscono la complessità
africana ma diciamo daranno un piccolo
assaggio
il vero problema della narrazione
sull'africa è questa malattia che si
chiama stereotipo qualche tempo fa forze
ha raccolto tutte le copertine degli
ultimi decenni di libri usciti
sull'africa io lo trovo sublime no
una caccia al tramonto ci sono saggisti
narratori penne africane per le europee
penne americane fiction non fiction
cosa fa il photoeditor come copertina
una traccia al tramonto io lo trovo un
po di fanta però c'è un po di fantasia e
cioè un elefantino che sta bruciando
l'erba che guizzo mamma mia
allora sì oggi cercherò di mostrarvi
come l'africa e molto altro ha delle
sfumature delle complessità e quindi ho
portato alcuni oggetti che avete intuito
hanno la loro importanza
ho scoperto che questa cosa si chiama
presenter io ero convinto che fosse un
telecomando metto il presente per qua
spero di ricordarmi di primo oggetto
sapete cos'è questo troppo facile non è
un machete cioè si è un machete ma
questa è un coltellino multiuso svizzero
ci potete fare qualsiasi cosa potete
macellare a fare pezzettini piccoli
piccoli piccoli una capretta sul bordo
strada a farci delle spedini e deliziosi
e mangiarli cosa che succede potete
togliere il fango dal vostro fuori
strada mentre vi siete impantanati e
uscire dal fango
potete aprirsi un varco nella foresta
nella giungla congolese equatoriale ed
aprire un nuovo sentiero
oppure potete molto più ragionevolmente
riservare un campo prima di darlo perché
questo è un attrezzo agricolo nasce come
attrezzo agricolo ma qua la prima
complessità
questa è la più grande arma di
distruzione di massa nel genocidio
ruandese del 94 è stato usato il machete
anche tante altre armi e fa giu
immediatamente troviamo come dire la
complessità le doppie facce le triple
facce delle storie ma torniamo
l'agricoltura al precipuo uso che vedo
che siete un po tesi
mi rassereno parliamo di agricoltura e
la storia dell'agricoltura è una breve
storia triste
un mio amico congolese belga scusate
lavora proprio energie si reca in congo
nel masisi è come se andare in svizzera
è bellissimo colline verdi alberi
meravigliosi mucche agricoltura vali
lavora per questi anni si e dice io
voglio introdurre la trazione agricola
bovina che vuol dire semplicemente visto
che hanno tante mucche attacchiamo
l'aratro è così quindi riassume maniera
un po puerile la conversazione che alex
il mio amico belga ha avuto con alcuni
tuzi congolesi e gli amici io vi do
l'aratro vedo che avete un sacco di mou
che potremo rare molto facilmente quel
campo è il lavoro che fate in un mese lo
facciamo in un giorno risposta no perché
perché la mucca serve per fare il latte
ma ho capito però sto dicendo che tu e
tua moglie potreste avere molto più
tempo per voi e quindi liberare forza
lavoro eccetera eccetera eccetera
eccetera
risposta no perché perché la mucca ci
facciamo gli spiedini fine della storia
triste alex ha lasciato il congo e se
n'è tornato triste e sconsolata in
belgio breve storia allegra due anni
dopo erano ganda e stava documentando
una serie di progetti dell'agricoltura
sostenibile un certo punto mentre faccio
le foto
vedo una serie di campi
meravigliosamente arati e alla fine
dell'ultimo campo cosa c'è un aratro è
attaccata cosa c'è una mucca non quella
dei divani prix già credo però c'è una
mucca cosa era successo un'altra ng
aveva preso un inglese un agronomo lo ha
mandato a specializzarsi a londra questo
agronomo superspecializzato era tornato
in uganda e va spiegato ai suoi
concittadini quanto fosse efficace ed
efficiente
l'attrazione agricola bovina e la
risposta era stata sì perché no allora
questa storia ci insegna che
nell'affrontare l'africa così come tante
altre cose ci sono delle barriere
culturali che non possiamo ignorare
e a volte l'ignoto e l'inconoscibile
rimangono tali perché noi pecchiamo di
arroganza e gli arriva l'uomo bianco che
salverà l'africa ecco molte volte questa
cosa
in funzione secondo oggetto sapete cos'è
questa no non è una radio cioè si è una
radio è una radio ma anche il social
network
questo è facebook e twitter messi
insieme ma ancora più figo
se vuoi girate in africa un'immagine
ricorrente ovunque nella foresta nella
savana nei villaggi nella città e questo
la gente gira con l'orecchio attaccato
alla radio la radio funziona tantissimo
radio comunitaria scusate prendo il
presenter la roba mi fa impazzire del
presente non so perché
ok la radio è il social il social
network ante litteram
immaginate zone rurali dove non c'è il
3g 4g attenzione in molte zone
dell'africa c'è il 4g e ma in alcune
zone non c'è anche qui complessità
diversità come immaginate zona dove dove
non ci si arriva dove ci metti tre
giorni per fare trenta chilometri dove i
percorsi sono veramente dei piccoli
trattori dove si cammina in fila indiana
ecco l'unico mezzo di comunicazione
questa cosa meravigliosa fatto questa la
compatta per 5 dollari a kigali made in
china bisogna fare un altro ted solo su
questo è cioè quelle robe cinesi in
africa
sarebbe bellissimo comunque vedete un po
di un po di noi io amo dare i numeri
detta così una bella però questi numeri
sono interessanti le 83 per cento dei
tanzaniani cerca informazioni sulla
radio in zambia la radio è il mezzo più
accessibile
mentre città più o meno tv e radio
funzionano se si va nelle zone rurali
funziona solo questa
in 11 paesi africani tra 2000 e il 2003
2000 2006 le radio comunitarie sono
cresciute del 1300 per cento come funghi
recentemente sono stato in congo e stavo
raccontando la crisi ebola stava
documentando con foto e video
vedo un po di terrore non sono
contagiosi comunque sono già passato
tranquilli potete singer me la mano
dello pozzo allora eroine ball appunto
eroina kong a raccontare a raccontare le
bolas laps suoi dana questa cosa stavo
raccontando la crisi ebola era stato
punto scoprono la potenza della radio in
tutta veramente la sua grandezza
perché in zona è veramente sperdute
foresta comunità pig me c'erano delle
le radio locali quindi capanne con un
generatore che sputa chiava l'antenna
attaccata al baobab no facciamo alla
caccia di prima al tramonto così che
davano in formazione informazione
sanitaria come proteggersi dal virus
come evitare la sua diffusione e la
gente sta attaccata alla radio la radio
funziona funziona nella campagne
elettorali e funziona per insegnare a
come si coltiva quando e come mandare i
bambini a scuola ha una funzione
pedagogica educativa sociale
ma attenzione c'è sempre il lato oscuro
in agguato la radio nel 94 quel famoso
famigerato benefico genocidio del 94 in
ruanda ha svolto un ruolo molto negativo
la cosiddetta radio libera delle mille
colline che di libero aveva soltanto il
nome era quella che gettò olio sul fuoco
incita all odio razziale contro contro
tutti e contro gli hutu moderati
e quindi in quel momento la radio svelò
tutto il suo potere benefico
penso di avere l'intensità è abbastanza
vero sì proprio sopra di meglio adesso
di rendo ancora più tristi immagino che
voi tutti abbiate in tasca questo
fantastico oggetto che cos'è questo è un
telefonino non oil
stavolta non c'è il giochino è un
telefonino basta quindi è un telefonino
su questo non ci piove ma sapete cosa
c'è dentro questo telefonino
questo ci sono le miniere di coltan cioè
c'è il colta nel colta in una roba
strana columbite tantalite si fa anche
fatica un po dirlo sono minerali
preziosissimi che vengono estratti in
pochissime zone del globo tra cui il est
del congo
questi minatori che vedete guadagnano 5
dall'area al giorno e non sanno cosa
stanno estraendo in queste zone si
combatte in queste zone si campa con
pochi delle regioni in queste zone si
muore o per un colpo di kalashnikov o
perché il tunnel dentro cui si stava
lavorando a un certo punto crolla
miseramente
ecco noi dobbiamo avere la
consapevolezza che a volte quello che
teneva in mano potrebbe come dire
provenire parte di quello che da milano
potrebbe provenire da quelle zone league
ma anche qua c'è il rovescio della
medaglia
finalmente due anni fa l'uno europea ha
introdotto un testo che introduce la
tracciabilità obbligatoria per 800 mila
imprese che utilizzano minerari
come questo anche qui ancora una volta
no si dice la complessità ma questa
storia ci insegna una cosa molto molto
interessante si insegna che a volte
l'ignoto l'inconoscibile rimangono tali
per mera convenienza economica perché le
aziende conveniva andare a pescare il
coltan senza farsi troppi scrupoli
andiamo avanti
sapete cos'è questo qua vi fregola cos'è
questo è un bicchiere d'acqua tra facile
no
questo non è un bicchier d'acqua vi do
una notizia questa è la corazza di iron
man o prendete un altro eroe della
marvel come sarà piazza d armi dove sta
la prova adesso voi siete invulnerabile
ai proiettili o anche un classico un
ak47 del solo proprio no scherza non lo
portava portarle macedone ak 47
allora questa storia interessantissima
verrà da sorridere ma quello che vedete
ritratto è un miliziano mai mai dovrei
dire magi magi magi una parola swahili
che deriva dall'arabo magi vuol dire
acqua queste milizie mai mai che sono
ancora molto molto diffuse credono nel
potere dell'invulnerabilità dell'acqua
ma ci credono davvero
e c'è gente anche conta che ha studiato
che ci crede come funziona la sera prima
della battaglia queste milizie mai mai
bisogna rispettare una serie di precetti
molto molto importanti primo progetto
non devi fare sesso con la tua donna
prima della battaglia
secondo progetto non devi fare sesso
prima della battaglia quella donna degli
altri non devi fare sesso prima della
battaglia che già uno dice di sì ma già
vado a combattere potrei morire non
posso no non puoi ok terzo progetto o
quarto non puoi mangiare del cibo che ti
è stato porto da una donna
ciò che è tutta una serie di altri
principi ma il giorno della battaglia se
avrete un giorno il fegato di andare in
battaglia sulla front line con i mai mai
troverete alla fine del protone un
miliziano che regge una tanica d'acqua
ea certo punto fra quello che ho fatto
prima con voi vi renderà invulnerabili
di asperger ad acqua e voi sarete
davvero intollerabili proiettili
no perché poi sparano e qualcuno muore e
rimane per terra ma questa meravigliosa
liturgia questa credenza incredibile dei
mai mai ha dentro di sè l'alibi quelli
che sono morti nel campo di battaglia
tra i mai mai perché sono morti perché
non hanno rispettato i precetti perché
l'ho visto quello lì che la sera prima
flirtava con fatto e lo so che poi no e
perché l'ho visto che ha mangiato le
foglie di manioca che la zia di aver
rapporto con la mano destra
ecco c'è un lato magico esoterico in in
africa che vi augura molto molto forte
certo è forte nelle zone rurali
soprattutto ma arriva fin dentro le
capitali mentre ero in congo appunto a
seguire la crisi ebola
mi dicevano che il virus ebola era
portato dagli spiriti oppure ogni tanto
io passavo in jeep tra i villaggi
salutavo e loro dicevano ebola ebola
ebola e secondo anche a voi perché
credevano che fossi io cioè o sono gli
spiriti all uomo bianco
pensate al fenomeno della tratta delle
ragazze nigeriane che vengono legate ai
loro sfruttatori tramite i riti gesù che
sono dei riti magici ci credono
esiste quindi una parte dell'africa che
noi non possiamo ignorare ma questa
storia qua questa rimane mai della magia
del latte esoterico ci dimostra una cosa
che a volte l'ignoto l'inconoscibile
rimangono tali per noi perché ci sono
delle cose che noi non possiamo
afferrare e quindi rimarranno così
adesso però gli proporrei di abbandonare
un po questa visione dell'africa che fa
molto figo un poco andrà lawrence cuore
di tenebra però un po anche polverosa no
l'africa anche tanto altro in uganda ci
sono aziende biologiche
ci sono imprese africane che stanno
investendo in europa e in ghana sono
delle startup che fanno dei mattoni per
fare le case con il riciclo delle noci
di cocco e poi sono esempi meravigliosi
c'è la settimana della moda in africa lo
sapevate
lagos johannesburg kampala in uganda io
ho fatto una serata sublime a kampala
con un fotografo consiglio molfese che
un po govi italiano che sembra
il oliviero toscani del dell'africa
praticamente no stavo praticamente stava
corso como 10 a milano una cosa
fichissima modelle musica alla moda era
tutto fantastico non c'era quella la
patina polverosa che noi ci immaginiamo
dell'africa in africa ci sono 23 mila
milionari che acquistano abiti di lusso
quella settimana della moda ripartita
nei vari paesi del continente entro il
2020 varrà 15 miliardi e mezzo di
dollari
alla faccia di quell'immagine
dell'africa che noi abbiamo in africa
centro e gc e il 4g si sono le
università ci sono le ferrovie in africa
c'è anche il film c'è il cinema
voi lo sapevate che nollywood
l'industria cinematografica di lagos è
la seconda o terza seconda per numero di
film prodotti o fatturato al mondo dopo
hollywood los angeles bollywood in india
chen hollywood in nigeria ma io tre anni
fa mi sono innamorato di loro
ramon film production waka likud fanno i
film a 200 dollari nelle bidonville
fanno delle robe sublimi allora il gusto
è quindi ne è discutibile nel senso che
la trama di solito è questa c'è uno che
spara a qualcuno poi arriva un altro e
spara a tutti no è un po allora loro
fanno decine di film il regista isaac
bawa ma è soprannominato il quentin
tarantino dell'uganda ora non abbiamo
tempi ma gli effetti speciali che fanno
loro sono i nostri anni 40 50
quell'elicottero che vedete che vola non
è vero non ce le hanno fanno dei
modellini di cartone li fanno schiantare
con altri modellini di cartone dei
palazzi fanno scoppiare un petardo e
hanno fatto l'effetto speciale per fare
il sangue e vi assicuro che c'è
tantissimo sangue nel film d'epoca le
mode ma tanto utilizzano dei
preservativi riempiti di succo di
pomodoro e li fanno esplodere
no per cui è insomma è una sarta però
fantastica e geniale e vendono migliaia
e migliaia di dvd ogni mese impiegando
giovani attori che si stanno formando
che stanno che stanno crescendo
vi racconto solo questa il mito di isaac
e sapete chi è una chat norris
ovviamente
detto isaac ma qual è il tuo sogno
voglio fare un film con chuck norris
nella foresta detto beh in bocca al lupo
ci riuscirai ha detto ma poi l'altro tuo
grande vanto che mi spiace è scomparso
ma bud spencer è il mio mito come bud
spencer perché sai noi facciamo
fondazione e perché fate solo fondazione
sai potremo fare film d'amore però
l'amore non è abbastanza universale alla
fine le barriere culturali le differenze
invece il cazzotto il cazzotto e
universale ha detto beh ci hai ragione
lo schiaffone di bud spencer lo
capiscono tutti io ho trovato isaac
veramente veramente geniale allora
quest'ultima storia ci dimostra come li
note l'inconoscibile a volte è un
cazzotto ma è un cazzotto piacevole ea
volte per abbracciare le note
l'inconoscibile basterebbe andare al
cinema per esempio e gustarsi qualcuno
di questi film
le conclusioni sono queste sono molto
molto semplici abbracciare l'ignoto e
inconoscibile per me è una molla
incoercibile perché faccio quello no
cioè face reporter di consumo gli
scarponi più o meno e quindi cerco di
andare a smontare gli stereotipi e cerca
di restituire la complessità le
contraddizioni avete sentito dalle
storie no c'è sempre il lato oscuro
ho tanti lati ecco perché io chiederei a
voi lo stesso sforzo di esigere da china
da chi narra da chi racconta restituirvi
la complessità le cose non sono 10 non
sono mani che non sono bianche e nere
se perdiamo le sfumature se perdiamo la
complessità
andiamo a perdere totalmente la
conoscenza e quindi mio invito è fare
uno sforzo con ben e quindi non mi resta
che prendere il machete e augurarvi un
bel in bocca al leone a tutti grazie
[Applauso]